our next application
of nonlinear least squares is non-linear
model fitting
and so we'll just look at what happens
when the parameters
enter the model in a non-affine
way when they enter in an affine way you
have just linear least squares and we
already know how to do that
so non-linear model fitting looks like
this
we have our predictor that's our model
or predictor f hat
of x i that is going to be
the ith feature vector and then
the parameter theta that's what we seek
to choose and then
this is the prediction so this is really
uh y
hat i right and this is the sum of the
squares
of the errors prediction errors right so
now the difference here is that um
we are not assuming uh that f
hat depends in an affine way on
theta now in the linear and the
parameters model it looks like this
and this is exactly this is the this is
the general case of what it would be
if f hat was a linear function of theta
that's called the linear in parameters
model
because it's a linear function of the
parameters of course it's not
necessarily a linear function of x and
usually is not
but it's a linear function of the
parameters
so here we're going to allow this f-hat
to be a non-linear function of
the model parameters and we'll see that
there's lots of examples of where that
can be helpful
it can also improve interpretability
things like that
and we're going to minimize over the uh
these the model parameters theta so
we'll look at a quick example uh
so we have some data and uh
for some reason we believe that it has
the form of a decaying
sinusoid okay so we're going to write it
this way
it's theta 1 times x theta 2
x theta 2 gives you the decay rate if
it's negative or
positive the growth rate and then cosine
term cosine theta 3
x plus theta 4. theta three is
essentially the
frequency of the sinusoid
and theta four gives you the offset or
phase for that
so so that's a that's that's a a model
that's parameterized by
four parameters and then your job is to
given some data points uh which you can
see on this plot
are the little green circles um given
the data points your job is to choose
theta one theta two theta three theta
four
uh to fit uh to to get a good fit
of with your data now
that ends up with a a non-linear least
squares problem
because you end up with this objective
you sum over all of your data points
this thing of course that's y hat that's
y
hat uh i like that um
and you can see that it doesn't end it's
not linear well actually i should say
one thing it is linear and theta one
so we can solve for theta one by a least
squares problem but
you know not theta two theta three and
theta four
okay um so this i i would say think
things like this are
are quite you know this is uh easily
done um
by using levenberg marquardt and in fact
i believe the fit that we're showing
there
is one computed from these data points
uh using levenberg mark right and you
can see it gets a it fits a decaying
sinusoid like
quite nicely okay um
the next uh example of this is something
called orthogonal
distance regression so um let's remember
that when you actually normally
fit a function what happens is you'd
have a curve like this
that's your that's your approximation
and you have a data point like this or
like that
something like that um what we what we
measure there is the
vertical distance between your data
point
and and the uh and the value of the
model here
that's that's the traditional thing if
you look at uh
if you look at traditional model fitting
you do that you you have the it's the
vertical distance between
uh the vertical distance between uh the
data point
and the uh and the function value
in some cases you literally want to fit
a curve and if you're fitting a curve
not a function i mean if you think of it
as a curve not a function
then basically what it does is you what
you really should do is look at the
actual distance to the curve
now the distance of the curve is defined
as the closest point on the distance of
the closest point on the curve
to u and so that means that
instead of penalizing the vertical
distance like this
we're actually if the curve looks like
that we're actually going to
penalize you for being away from the
curve so that's it
this would be as if in in this case
you're not really thinking of this as a
function you're thinking of it more as a
relation or a curve
this picture uh shows you you know how
you would do that uh what the picture is
uh for that um and you know it's
similar to but slightly different from
um the uh it's slightly different from
normal fitting actually the main point
here is that you're allowed
uh when you have a data point you're
allowed not to associate it with the
same value of
x you're actually allowed to mess with
the x and
and compare it to a slightly different
one so actually sometimes people call
this an error
error in the features model because
we're also what we're
giving ourselves license to do is to
actually uh change the value of x
associated with with uh the a data point
so that looks like this um
so we'll write it out as a non-linear
least squares problem
what we'll do is we'll take the
the difference in in the y's but we're
going to evaluate it at a ui
ui is going to be a variable like i said
we don't actually if you spit
ui if you insist ui equals x i we're
back where we were before
but we're going to do is we're actually
going to allow you to mess with that and
then we're actually going to penalize
you
for um for basically moving uh choosing
an
x that uh sorry an x value called ui
which is not the same as the given x
value x i um and that if you if you look
at this
this case in in well in 1d uh you get
you kind of get the idea
uh that the the distance to the curve
here
is two things it's the vertical distance
which we're kind of
with that that that's the one that we're
that's this term right and then there's
this term
right here uh u and x are uh scalars so
it's just the absolute value so it's the
sum
the square root of the sum of the
squares and the distance squared
is the sum of the squares so here what
we're going to do is we're going to this
is we're going to optimize in this
problem
over the following variables theta those
are the
the model parameters and ui so by the
way even in this case if theta enters
uh linearly into f hat so it's a linear
in the parameters model
even in this case this is a a nonlinear
uh least squares problem because we also
have
the uis there uh which we're allowed to
mess with okay
so that is um this is th
this is a um a uh
this is called orthogonal distance
regression i guess it's called
orthogonal because
you associate with each point um a point
on the curve on the on on the graph of
the function
um and the tangent to the function there
is orthogonal to the
to the deviation from that point to um
to the given data point so that's why
it's called orthogonal distance
regression but you'll hear this and
you'll see this in in a bunch of
applications
the next topic is non-linear least
squares classification
um so let's see how this works um
well recall that in a linear least
squares classifier what we do
is we uh first we fit by the least
squares
um an f tilde of x uh that's simply a
a regression or a a model prediction
that predicts
the real number uh that it should be is
ideally close to minus one or plus one
that's the idea then of course we're not
allowed if someone says
for this for this feature vector do you
think it's true or false you're not
allowed to say it's 0.6 or something
or or partly true or something like that
what you'll do instead is we'll take the
sign of that
so that's that that's the actual
that's the actual predictor okay and
this is we just use
ordinary least squares to do this now a
non-linear least squares classifier
uh does this it starts with the
following observation
if we're going to work directly with the
sign right in in
in least squares classification we don't
use
we don't use the sign at all that's a
post process right we simply use least
squares which you know how to do we fit
it
and then we take the sign and actually
the weird part is it kind of works
pretty well
often but okay here we're going to take
into a fact into account the fact that
we're going to use the sign
so let's see how this works um
sine of f hat of x i has only two values
plus or minus one
y i has only two values plus or minus
one so
if i subtract them you either get zero
if they agree
or you get uh minus e they get plus two
or minus two
and those are the two cases when it
doesn't agree now when you square plus
two or minus two
you get four so it turns out the sum
over the data of sine f tilde of x i
minus y i
squared is actually four times the
number of errors
so now what we're going to do we're
going to directly
or not directly not quite we're going to
attempt to minimize that
because we really would like to pick
parameters for which our model makes
as few errors as possible okay so let's
try that
oh one minor problem sine of f tilde of
x
is discontinuous and so it's not
differentiable right it's because
the sine function you know goes like
this it's kind of it's got a it's got a
jump at zero uh in this case it's where
f tilde of x is zero
actually interestingly it's got a jump f
tilde of x equals zero
is sort of some people call that the
confusion point because in the
classifier
if you know f tilde of x equals zero
means
i don't know it could be minus one or
plus one you know f tilde equals point
three means okay
i think f hat should be one minus point
three means f h should probably be minus
one
uh but zero means like i don't know i
don't know so
it's a decision and at that this at that
confusion point i should say
it's actually not there's a big jump
it's not differentiable so
what we do instead is you just simply
replace sine
with a differentiable approximation of
it for example
a sigmoid function which i'll show you
uh shortly and then you just use
uh levenberg mark where to minimize this
it's a non
it's just fine it's a non linear least
squares problem
okay so here's a sigmoid function you'll
probably see this in a whole bunch of
different things but that's
that's it and the idea is you know
here's the sine function right
and the sigmoid function is like a
smooth approximation of it
so that's the idea so we just have a we
just have a sigmoid function
uh in there like that and that's that's
that's what we're gonna do
okay so um this actually works
actually shockingly well um so uh we'll
go back
to the mnist uh handwritten digit data
set
the very very famous data set these days
or not anymore because
people moved on but much bigger ones
cfar and stuff like that okay
so um but the feature vector here x is a
493 vector of pixel intensities
i think including one that's constant
right so that's it and we're going to
make a non-linear least squares 10 way
multi-class classifier so um
and uh when we do this i mean you get
down to 7.5 percent error
on on this um so
um so the the boolean classifiers are
computed by solving this nonlinear
um least squares problem right which
says it says minimize this
and we take phi to be a sigmoid here um
here we have regularization and sure
enough as
lambda gets bigger we actually improve
uh on our test error and so we should
take lambda somewhere in this region
right here
right so we could take it to be i don't
know 0.3
0.5 i don't know something like that
somewhere somewhere in that
in that in that range
so that's how that works um okay we're
gonna take that same problem
and we're gonna do a little bit of
feature engineering we're gonna do
profoundly stupid feature engineering
which is we're gonna generate
5000 random features which is you take a
linear
you take random linear combinations then
you take the sign or something no
uh sorry positive part right and that's
just our
i mean you could do way way better if
you sort of did handcrafted features but
this is just to show you what happens if
you just do some feature engineering
the test set error in this case drops to
two percent
um by the way that's the performance of
human beings
on recognizing digits in other words if
you simply take those digits
show them to a person and they're like
yeah that's right you just say
usually this would be like an undergrad
or something like that we'd force them
to do it or something in a class and be
it
that'd be part of the class is you have
to look at
you know 300 digits and type in whether
it's zero to nine
that's it um when you do that uh that
the test set error drop for people sorry
for people
they get an error rate that's about two
percent um so
about one in fifty and you know some of
these things are written these
handwritten things are written pretty
poorly
right um and sometimes you would look at
it you'd say that is a seven
and then but the data would say that's a
nine or at least that person thought
they were writing a nine
it looks like a seven but it's a nine um
so
all right so that means that just you
know using
pretty much the material of this book in
class
um you match human performance
it's actually really kind of a stunning
thing to think about briefly because if
you think about like how dumb
what's happening is but you understand
all the moving parts it's just pixels
um the algorithm you put together which
would be levenburg marquardt on this
thing
it uh it doesn't it it knows
it's profoundly stupid it does not know
what integers are
it knows nothing um and yet here it is
classifying
classifying digits um just as well as
people are
now if you do more feature engineering
you can easily
beat uh human performance substantially
which starts getting weird and creepy if
you think about it
i should also add that you know with uh
i mean there's other methods
this is an ideal problem for these uh
classifier classifiers called neural
networks
and they they can easily get superhuman
performance on these like just
easily i should add that you can
actually minimize
uh you can fit neural networks using
levenberg marquardt
anyway uh so this shows you that just
you know putting together some bits and
pieces from this course you actually get
to
maybe not the state of the art but
you're not too far behind and at least
it demystifies
how all these things work this is kind
of how they all work if you
go and look at how these are actually
done on your internships or whatever
you'll you'll see that it's very similar
to the stuff we've been talking about
you